hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game uh that was played I
believe the day before yesterday it's a
game from the shaft Bundesliga and it's
a game between Czech Grand Master lost
email and Serbian Grandmaster Alexander
kolachevich and it's uh it's basically a
story of one player swimming
um uh in a pool of favorable
continuations uh and then he just drowns
and there are so many favorable
continuations here uh that the uh the
the the the the drowning sequence will
will shock you so let's dive straight
into it uh last email has the white
pieces and he opens with the D4 and we
have the first um some 12 moves are
known Theory Knight to F6 with C for E
uh sorry C4 not C3 C4 E6 Knight to F3
and the D5 yeah which goes for the
Queen's Gambit declined with knights the
C3 and Bishop to B4 so the aragos in
defense not as fancy as the nimsel but
still very nice we have Queen to A4
check night to see this is the AL yankin
variation Knights the C6 and now Pawn to
E3 we have castles and queen back to C2
now this is all uh very well known stuff
nothing new here Rook to E8 and the
bishop to D2 We have a6a3 uh challenging
the bishop and the bishop goes back to
D6 so Bishop D6 you could also consider
bishop p7 or Bishop to f8
uh Bishop to D6 is what kovacio which
goes for H3 we have H6 and now C
captures and D5 we have e captures on D5
and Bishop to D3 putting uh the queen
and Bishop on this diagonal so very
nicely placed and now there is a game uh
between uh Victor waznichka and the
Shakira mamidyar of from Dean uh from
from the World Cup in 20 uh 2009 uh
where Bishop to D7 was played at
mamajaro one but here we have Bishop to
E6 and now there there is a game where
Ponte G4 was played but here uh we have
um uh Queen side castles and it is now
as of move 13 then we have a completely
new game and this is basically where our
game starts and now uh as uh okay you
have castles on opposite sides of the
board and now uh kovachi it should
definitely consider well just starting
an attack on the queen side something
like B5 and the one starts uh y starts
attacking on the king side already B4
and black is the the one who starts
attacking first however he starts with
Bishop to D7 he doesn't mind giving up
the attacking uh well privileges over to
white and white goes for it a babula
that goes for G4 we have B5 and now G5
so now a white is the one who starts the
attack first H characters Knight
captures now with all
this control over the H7 square but just
Pawn to B4 attacking the Knight here so
a captures Knight captures and now Queen
to B1 and here uh you could consider
with something like C5 but Knight
captures on D3 uh that Bishop does seem
to be very strong but on the other hand
you allow now Queen captures on D3 and
then the queen will be attacking the H7
Square uh might have been better to have
the bishop attacking the H7 square but
okay uh Queen captures on D3 Queen to C8
and now Knight captures on D5 and this
is uh this is a very nice move by white
because black wants to play Rook to B8
and he wants to play Bishop to F5 to
attack the White Queen but black missed
Knight captures on D5 and now the point
is if you go Bishop to F5 it's not as
impressive you will play Knight captures
on F6 and after G capture is now black
no longer controls the E4 Square uh Pawn
to E4 attacks the bishop
so you're gonna go back uh now the
Knight is attacked and after Knight to
F3 uh now you continue the attack with
something like Rook to B8 or queen to B7
basically you want to have heavy pieces
on the B file going after that B2 Pawn
uh the problem is if you go something
like Bishop captures an E4 then Rook H
the G1 check and black is just the
doomed let's say King to h8 Queen E3 now
going after the H6 square and if Bishop
to f8 and now just Knights the E5 and uh
there is no defense here the bishop is
hanging Knight captures on F7 is the
threat uh not much you can do here let's
say root captures an e5d captures an E5
now Bishop to H7 just Queen to F3 now
again attacking F6 there's there's too
much stuff Happening Here black will not
be able to withstand this
uh so after this uh Knight captures on
D5 Moon we have Knight captures on D5 by
kovachovich Quinta H7 check King to f8
and now Pawn to e for attacking the
Knight Knight to F4 and now Queen to h8
with check with King the E7 and queen
captures and G7 so white made a lot of
progress here forcing the black king all
the way to E7 but Knight to E2 with
check with King to B1 and now Bishop to
E6 uh controlling this diagonal you can
see the Knight also controlling a lot of
squares here and the position is now
completely winning for y to make no
mistake here that's why I I said that at
the beginning of the video even though
it was kind of weird uh but yeah let's
say Knight captures on F7 and you just
resign here there's nothing you can do
here with black if you capture the
Knight just Bishop G5 check and now if
you go here okay we capture the bishop
if you go to E6 then first D5 check King
here and now you go for Queen captures
and F7 but Bishop D7 and now any move
here just wins for white lets you bring
the Rook to E1 not much for black to do
here but after Bishop E6 E5 was played
and this gives black an idea
uh Rook the B8 uh very very tricky move
by black uh because Knight captures on
F7 is still winning uh it's pretty much
the same idea I like the move before but
black probably thought uh okay white
missed it the first time maybe white
misses it for the second time or maybe
he also missed that he was winning it's
very hard to say but in the game e
captures and D6 check happened and now
white is no longer winning but he might
be losing he's not objectively losing
the objectively it's it's still a
playable position for both but after C
captures on D6 now you have to play
Knight captures on E6 Knight captures
and F7 no longer works but that's
exactly what uh what babula played he
played Knight captures on F7 and now the
position is completely winning for black
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find it the only move that not only
wins the game for black but uh forces
white to resign on the Spot while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
uh all of the squares are taken the
bishop covers uh this Square The Rook
controls B2 the Knight control C1 and
and C3 and uh well if if we are if we
also gain control over this diagonal uh
could be very very important and you
can't just play anything you've played
Bishop to F5 this will not be enough
then King day one and white is still
winning uh but for those of you who
found Queen to C2 with check
congratulations as that is the way to
win this game absolutely stunning idea
uh we can even do it in slow motion as I
mean what a move Queen the city with
check and now you're saying now I don't
care if you go to A1 if you go to A1 now
Queen captures and B2 is Checkmate so
you have to capture the queen that's the
only other legal move and after Queen
cap King captures Queen and C2 now not
Bishop to B3 check because then the king
escapes the D3 but Bishop to F5 and this
is now trackmate and the game actually
ended with Bishop to F5 Checkmate on
move 29 so I dare say it this can be
considered a modern miniature even
though uh it's not a classical miniature
where you're just better right from the
opening and then you crush your opponent
here black was winning for the entire
time uh if if he only played Knight
captures an F7 sooner but he wanted more
like I said there were so many good
moves for white uh he just couldn't
decide what to play and then you know he
just dragged the game along uh dragged
it on dragged it on until uh he fell for
this queen characters on C2 check we can
show it one more time I know you guys
want to see it one more time Queen to
see to checking captures and the bishop
to F5 Checkmate absolutely spectacular
uh so yeah uh brilliant brilliant uh
game by both of them but uh the win goes
to Alexander kovachovich who spots Queen
to C2 and uh I mean uh the the holidays
are not even here yet but it's it's like
I mean with games like these we can
definitely uh sense the the spirit of
the of the holidays uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and uh
once again big congratulations to
everyone who spotted that Queen to see
to move uh you have quite the Keen Eye
uh I would like to thank Ahmed Yousef uh
Anup akihal uh clothes box and ravishing
reptiles YouTube for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions uh such as this one uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day